je suis désolé mais c'est vu dans
arrestation pour extorsion
de Pietro
les années 80 c'est la fin de la crise pour toi
c'est une opportunité que cette fois la mienne
l'esprit d'entreprise vous ne le croyez pas
devient député
maintenant c'est notre tour
et toujours dit que tu le ferais
tout pour moi maintenant que je ne le fais pas
je veux pas faire tellement je veux
dimanche dans
tant qu'il y a de l'aide dans les internets et m
si dangereux
veut y arriver mais craxi ne le fera plus jamais
ce nom est un mot de fenêtre tragique
pour viser haut il faut le
les épaules couvertes arrêtent de ne pas faire confiance
personne n'est
nous savons comment cela fonctionne en le demandant
personne ne se sent intouchable
Que puis-je faire pour vous, donnez-moi 800 millions
et je recommanderais de l'essayer jamais
faire des choses horribles
Que faisons-nous ici
si nous voulons sauver la république de
bananes je veux qu'elles soient ouvertes comme une seule
la personne
couper ce qu'ils veulent est une blague
bon marché ont déjà pris à quoi
il fallait trouver de l'énergie ha
[ __ ] tu as tout pris en compte
rappelle le sodium
aujourd'hui le système s'est effondré mais faisons le
l'histoire
messieurs rock and roll bienvenue à
tangentopoli
cela signifie que maintenant commande votre il
immense pouvoir de la télévision
la situation est excellente
nous cassons le troisième album et en plus
riche en Italie d'après toi combien là-bas
ils achètent quelqu'un
et c'est la politique de faire des promesses
non entretenu
comme ce qu'il a toujours voulu
ceux que je te nomme, elle ne sait pas
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour ce travail
nous parions que je comprends
le cachot fait semblant d'y croire
ça marche toujours